[Music]
straight ahead all
on crime daily a record-breaking
settlement for the city of minneapolis
in the death of george floyd what the 27
million dollars means
to his friends family and community this
is but one
step on the journey to justice
and our look back at a week in jury
selection for derek children's murder
trial
the questions and responses from
potential jurors are you
open to the possibility that police
reform is not needed
no plus it's been one year since the
fatal shooting of brianna taylor
the federal investigation is still open
and the local prosecution into her
boyfriend
now ordered closed and why a groping
allegation involving new york's governor
andrew cuomo
is now referred to law enforcement law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
antoinette levy's in minneapolis for
jury selection in the derek chauvin
trial
but first she has news of a major
settlement in the george floyd civil
case
yeah brian that settlement 27 million
dollars the minneapolis city council
approved that settlement on the fourth
day of jury selection in derrick
chauvin's criminal trial
this is not the first time we've heard
talk about a possible settlement
earlier in the week it was brought up
during a motion hearing
by eric nelson that is derek chovin's
attorney
now that offer has been accepted by
george floyd's family
it includes five hundred thousand
dollars for the neighborhoods
surrounding the intersection where floyd
died last may that is the intersection
of 38th and chicago
members of floyd's family attorney ben
crump and minneapolis city leaders spoke
about the settlement at a news
conference
if i could get him back i will give all
of this back
him i know that he's with us
and he's standing up right now knowing
that
we have the opportunity to be able to
fund
low-income african-american communities
and that's big in our heart as my family
stand here because
we are a product of our environments we
come from low income we come from the
cuny homes
the largest pre-trial
settlement in a police civil rights
wrongful death case in u.s
history makes a statement
that george floyd deserved better
than what we witnessed on may 25th 2020
that george floyd life matters
and by extension black lives matter
on behalf of the entire city council
offer my deepest condolences to the
family of george floyd
his friends and all in our community who
are mourning his loss
no amount of money can ever address the
intense pain or trauma caused by this
death
to george floyd's family or to the
people of our city
minneapolis has been fundamentally
changed by this time of racial reckoning
the city of minneapolis has made changes
many policy changes within the police
department since george floyd's death
that includes changes to the use of
force policies
now after george floyd's death even
placing
your hands an officer placing their
hands on someone is considered a use of
force
and an officer has to document that and
show
why he or she decided to place their
hands
on a member of the public brian thanks
internet
here to discuss the settlement between
the city of minneapolis and the estate
of george floyd
is criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin
bernarda as you heard ben crump saying
there this is the largest pre-trial
civil rights
wrongful death settlement in u.s history
what does that mean
uh in terms of a settlement on the heels
of a criminal trial
so brian no amount of money will ever
bring back the life of george floyd
however
this settlement of 27 million dollars
being the largest settlement
in u.s history for a wrongful death at
the hands of police officers
sends a powerful message and that
powerful message is that
the lives of black people matter and
that
police brutality must stop i'm hoping
though that this settlement does not
impact the deliberations on the trial
for
officer former officer derrick chavez
because on one hand
those jurors can think oh the city
settled for that high amount of money it
must have been
something wrong that he did and he is
culpable
or on the other hand they can say oh
well the city already settled they have
money so
maybe you know this will help in finding
him not guilty
um and taking away the burden on them
terry bernardo's kind of
weaved into the question i was going to
ask you could we or should we be reading
into the city settlement
before the trial and do you think it
could have any effect on jury selection
well bernardo did hit it on the head i
will tell you that because
it may actually affect jury selection
and i think
one of the things that both the defense
and the prosecution and the judge for
that matter
are going to want to do is to make sure
that the jury is not
affected by this settlement they may
need to ask did you hear about the
settlement
did you hear about the number and how
large it was
and will that affect you so i think they
just have to make sure
that even if they know about the
settlement it's not going to affect
their opinion
and they will make sure they listen to
the law and apply it to this case
definitely going to add a question in
that questionnaire during voir dire
angenet
i heard one of floyd's uh attorneys
issued a challenge to the corporations
in
minnesota sorry after the settlement
right
yeah that's right brian you know one of
the attorneys said he was challenging
the corporations in minnesota who said
that they are
they care about black lives and that
they advocate for police reform or
support police reform
that attorney challenged the
corporations in minnesota
to match that 500 000 for that
neighborhood
where george floyd died it's in an
economically depressed neighborhood
there are a lot of african-american
owned and
minority businesses there so he was
really challenging them to match that
five hundred thousand dollars
some of the reporters in the room
chuckled when he said that kind of as to
think
okay we'll wait and see if that happens
and we will wait and see if that happens
thank you
still ahead on law and crime daily it's
been a year since the death of brianna
taylor
no one is charged with her death but
what has happened since
but first back to the corner for jury
selection in the derrick chervin trial
our recap of week one you don't want to
miss
[Music]
welcome back the first week of jury
selection in derek children's trial
has wrapped up angela levy has the
latest on what questions potential
jurors are being asked in a high profile
case in the death of george floyd
brian so far seven jurors have been
selected five are men
and two are women and this is really one
of the most important parts of the trial
because those 12 jurors who are finally
selected will determine derek chovin's
guilt
or innocence when you first
received your jury notice
what was your initial reaction i was
super excited
excited yeah there were some
light-hearted moments during the first
week of jury selection in the trial of
derrick chauvin
go ahead and throw me under the bus with
your fiance okay i will do that
but for the most part the questions were
very serious
about jurors ability to be impartial and
make a decision about the death of
george floyd and derek chauvin's
culpability
based solely on the evidence presented
in the courtroom
we need police reform i mean are you
open to the possibility that police
reform is not needed
no the defense used a strike to
eliminate that juror
derek chovin and george floyd have
become names known around the world
after a cell phone video of floyd's
arrest went viral
but that won't be the only evidence the
jury hears and sees
attorneys are also mining social media
accounts of potential jurors
you posted and you have an opinion that
that 38th in chicago is sacred ground or
holy ground i don't remember what you
use
right the defense questioned the juror
about whether he could actually be
impartial
would you be able to proudly say to your
friends
and facebook followers and family
members i was a juror
who found mr chauvin not guilty
um i guess i
that's i can imagine that possibility
that's probably his most uh best i can
answer that
and that juror was stricken by the
defense
now we want to tell you a little bit
more about the jurors who've been
selected so far
the three men three of or three of the
men are white men
one man is an african-american man who
is actually an immigrant who came here
from africa
and another has been identified as being
hispanic or latino
and then there are the two women one of
the women has identified as multi-racial
and the other woman is a white woman
three weeks have been scheduled for jury
selection
ryan thanks angela here to break down
the first week of jury selection in the
trial of derek showman
is criminal defense attorney bernardo
violona and terry austin
terry we have seven jurors selected so
far what do you make of the jury
based on their background responses so
far
well you know i think angenette made a
very good case for
stating that the jury is very diverse
from a demographic standpoint we have
men and women we have different
backgrounds as far as race is concerned
i think however we also have people who
have different occupations and have had
different lifestyles we have a single
mom
we have an accountant we have someone
who's a chemist
we have an i.t specialist so i think
it's important to make sure you have
these diverse perspectives
people who can think logically and
here's what i'll end with i think the
most important thing
is that these jurors keep an open mind
both the defense and the prosecution
know and understand that these jurors
are coming in with a state of mind and
making sure they keep an open mind is
really critical bernard jury selection
often sees
themes that lawyers will use to prove
their case what themes do you see uh
manifesting so far so brian usually you
know as a trial attorney your first
interaction with the jury is when you
are selecting the jury and you are
supposed to
at least as the best trial attorney is
sell your narrative from the very
beginning
however in this case i am not seeing
that and the main reason why we're not
seeing that is because both parties are
more focused on
getting a fair and impartial juror using
the small amount of strikes that they
have remember the defense has 50
currency strikes
and the prosecution has nine and they're
about being each of these potential
jurors one at a time
so let's say they're trying to eliminate
bias rather than creating a narrative on
their own and jeanette
you've been there for a whole week now
do you think we'll get to 14 jurors
potentially by next week
you know it's hard to say you know a lot
of these jurors have been dismissed for
cause
others have been stricken by the
prosecution and the defense
but it's entirely possible we have seven
they need 14 that's the 12 jurors and
the two alternates
so it's very possible they could get
through it yesterday
on thursday i should say rather there
was only one juror seated
and then you know this could move
quickly or it could move slowly it's
just been
different numbers of jurors seated on
each day yeah it could be a lot quicker
especially when peremptory challenges
start to exhaust and you've got to just
pick whoever you get be sure to check
out the law and crime
network for gallaudet gamble coverage of
the derrick chauvin trial in the murder
of george floyd
coming up on law and crime daily an
inside look into how an ohio woman fled
the country
after she was implicated in the murder
of her husband plus
the court makes a final ruling on briana
taylor's boyfriend's case
what he thinks the case was really about
and his words for brianna taylor
[Music]
next
we're back march 12th marks one year
since brianna taylor was killed in her
apartment
by law enforcement a federal
investigation into the shooting remains
open
while the criminal case against her
boyfriend is now permanently closed
the department of justice's civil rights
investigators are looking into the
handling of the briana taylor case
the grand jury and panel by kentucky's
attorney general indicted one officer
for endangering taylor's neighbor during
the shooting prosecutors dismissed the
charges against taylor's boyfriend
kenneth walker two months after taylor's
death but left the opportunity to
revisit charges
if new information surfaces now a judge
has signed an order to permanently close
his case
walker spoke out last september when he
announced his lawsuit against the city
state and law enforcement the police
arrested
jail and charged me with murder of a
police officer
i was raised by a good family i am a
legal gun owner and i would never know
when we shoot a police officer
rihanna and i did not know who was
banging on the door
but the police know what they did the
charges brought against me
were meant to silence me and cover up
rihanna's murder
for her and those that i love i can no
longer remain silent
here to discuss the latest in the
federal investigation into the death of
brianna taylor
and kenneth walker's case is criminal
defense attorney bernardo violona
and co-host terry austin terry what's
this final order for walker mean in
terms of his criminal case
and how is that going to affect his
civil case
you know brian this is a very good
development for walker but i just don't
know why it took so long
the whole incident occurred back in
march of 2020
and back then he was charged with
assault and attempted murder against a
police officer there was even talk back
then
that they were going to drop the case
against him
and now finally judge stevens has said
that it is dropped with prejudice and
this is going to help
his civil case he's saying that he was
falsely arrested and detained
and the fact that the case against him
has been dropped
will help his civil case against the
city yeah it's dropped and no matter
what new information they find they're
not going to reopen it is basically what
we're finding out
bernard breakdown what a federal
investigation into the handling of
taylor's case means
is the ag being investigated so the
federal investigation
is the last chance of a prosecution for
the death of brianna taylor
unfortunately since the state
weren't wasn't able to bring charges
against those
officers so one thing about this federal
investigation is that it's more
broad it's not just those officers that
were involved in the killing of biannua
taylor
but they have expanded it to take into
account the actions the police actions
of getting a warrant
what were the officers thinking before
the different policies
how did we get there how did this
actually happen
so it's much more fraud and also looking
into the players
that had some kind of role in the death
of brianna taylor in addition to that
officer who lied on the search warrant
when he got that search warrant that he
uh investigated and spoke to postal
people in order to corroborate
that there was mail that was being
received at that location
unfortunately in this case as we saw
with the state is that a wall got more
justice
than the killing of a human being
exactly and of course
that that execution of the search
warrant is going to be really big and
how that warrant was founded
i think it'll be a big part of the
federal investigation when we come back
allegations against new york governor
andrew cuomo are increasing
as another woman's alleged talent is
brought to life and what albany police
and law enforcement are doing about it
next
welcome back an ohio woman could spend
the rest of her life behind bars
after the state's court of appeals
upheld her conviction for the murder of
her husband
law and crime's jesse weber explains the
nearly decade-long prosecution
of claudia herrig hey there brian yeah
it's all about claudia herrig on
tonight's episode
this is the woman who shot and killed
her husband air force major carl herrig
and then fled to brazil for over 10
years but when she was finally
extradited and arrested
what followed is really something you
have to see
to believe not only did she get into
quite the back and forth with the
prosecutor at her trial
but wait till you hear what she told
investigators
i got very angry if he had
said that i would be there he would be
alive
we're going to get into the shooting her
possible motivations and
also the deal that the u.s struck with
brazil that may surprise
many tune in to law on crime
thanks jesse a sexual harassment
accusation against new york's governor
andrew cuomo
has been referred to the police for
investigation into a possible crime
calls for governor cuomo to resign are
ramping up after
allegations by a sixth woman have been
made public
officials at the albany police
department say the governor's office and
state police
have been notified about an alleged
incident at the governor's mansion
involving a female aide and cuomo last
year the times union published the
woman's account
in which a person with direct knowledge
of the account says cuomo aggressively
groped the woman
in a sexually charged manner an attorney
for the woman says she does not want to
make a report to police
law and crimes adam claspell spoke to
the editor of the times union
on his podcast objections so quite apart
from any
what anyone has to say about any one
particular scandal that
uh governor cuomo has survived over the
course of his political career would it
be fair to say that there's
a pattern of allegations swirling around
him
of him meddling with institutions of
accountability
uh meant to put a check on his power
yes that is that is a through line
of all of the trouble that the governor
not all of the trouble but much of the
trouble that the governor has gotten
into
and certainly in this case an almost
shakespearean flaw
that the man has you can call it a
shakespearean flaw because
you know as in so many shakespeare
shakespeare characters
his virtues are so close to
his faults right in cuomo's case it is
control you know when the when there is
a flood
the governor wants to be there you know
uh wading through the water when there
is a snowstorm he wants to be
helping drag your truck out of the out
of the snowy ditch right
he wants his hands in everything
the flip side of that the flaw is
the pathological horror at
any independent investigation
that has anything to do with him back
one last time to discuss new allegations
against the governor of new york is
bernardo villalona and terry austin
grinarda you're a former prosecutor at
this point is it a matter of if
or when charges are filed against the
governor
so brian what i am hoping that even as a
former prosecutor and something that you
need to take into account
are there is there any basis for any
charges in this case
these are all allegations and what the
prosecutor is going to have to do
in this case is to take into account the
political climate
and what i see happening here is that
it's political football
of people going after mr coleman
governor fomo
and that if he's able to weather the
storm then he'll continue as governor
and there's no charges that are filed
right now the person that's doing the
investigation
in charge of the investigation is former
southern district u.s attorney mr coon
so we'll see what happens
now terry that kind of handles the
criminal aspect
but these allegations could go beyond an
investigation
and it could have i don't know civil or
even political ramifications right
exactly i mean the way i see it he's
facing a triple
threat on the political side he could be
impeached by the state senator and
they're already talking about that and
moving forward
on the criminal side clearly his victims
could claim
that these are assaults and they could
find from the investigation
that they were sexual assaults and on
the civil side this could take a lot of
time it could take money
there's no question that from an
employment perspective the women who
he employed and those women are claiming
that he
sexually harassed him that could be a
big civil case against him so
he's facing a lot right now absolutely
we'll keep an eye on those allegations
as they develop thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you